hello guys welcome back in this video we are going to learn about market structure
if you're looking at a bullish trend if you want to identify a bullish trend you
would be looking for higher high and higher lows so what is higher high and
higher lows this is considered as higher high high low higher high high low higher
high and higher low this state of market is considered to be bullish when you see
market creating higher highs and higher lows then that market is considered to
be bullish when you want to identify a bearish trend you would be looking for
lower lows lower highs lower lows lower highs so this is what lower low and lower
high looks like
lower low lower high lower low lower high lower low when you see market
constantly creating lower lows lower highs you will know that the market is
in bearish condition okay so for bullish market we need to identify price
creating higher high high low higher high low and in case of bearish market if
you want to identify a bearish market you would be looking for lower low lower
high lower low lower high then we got another market condition known as
ranging market now what is a ranging market when price is not moving in any
direction but it is moving within a small range so this type of price action is
considered to be ranging when you see this type of market it is considered to
be a ranging market and I have a strategy based on their ranging market
condition so there are three types of market structures we got a bullish
market structure we got a bearish market structure and then we got the
ranging market structure so this is a very simple textbook definition of
market structure now let's go let's suppose that you are looking at a market
structure on a five-minute time frame you are gonna see that price is making
higher highs and higher lows but when you drop down to one-minute time frame
you are gonna see that the market
oops sorry my bad let me draw this out and then I'll explain
okay so I'm gonna change the color of this and make it a little
oops not that is a bad color let me change it to something yellowish okay
wow this is bad this is bad wait wait okay so when you drop down to one
minute time frame you are gonna see that in this five-minute time frame
like to the downside we have a downtrend right but so you can see that the price
is fractal all right so let me just move this away you see this is we are
looking at this on a five-minute time frame but when you're gonna drop down
to one-minute time frame you're gonna see something like this in a uptrend on
the five-minute time frame you can see a downtrend on a one-minute time frame I
hope that definition is clear on an uptrend on a five-minute time frame
you can see a downtrend on a one-minute time frame so what does that tell us it
means that we can trade on any time frame it doesn't matter if you are
trading on a daily time frame it doesn't matter if you're trading on a early
time frame or it doesn't even matter if you're trading on a one-minute time
frame if you know about market structure you can trade literally on any time
frame so yeah I hope this clears everything about market structure so you
can see that the price would be creating low lows lower highs on this
leg of five-minute time frame so a small pullback on a five-minute time frame
could be a big downtrend on a smaller time frame so let's say you were looking
at this chart on an hourly time frame one-hour time frame on the pullback on one
hour time frame what you will do is you will then drop down to five-minute time
frame and then you're gonna see something like this you will see a downtrend on a
five-minute time frame but on the hourly time frame the overall trend is bullish
so this is what I'm gonna teach you in the upcoming videos and how you can trade
knowing that if a if a market is bullish in one time frame you can trade the
market as bearish in a smaller time frame I hope that clears what I'm trying to
say I'm sorry if my English is bad or it's hard for you to understand the
certain concepts but I'm trying my best here so this was all about market
structure I hope it's clear and I will see you guys in the next video